more weird Grimace merch that I found
when I was making my Grimace Horror
history episode so this is the pre-911
Grimace merchandise I don't think they
make this anymore and then this
Christmas Grimace merge I can't decide
if this is creepy or if it's just the
lighting that makes it creepy you guys
can let me know in the comments this one
is also very creepy I don't know what
this is just the fact that like there's
no other color pigmentation besides the
purple and the eyes just feel so Hollow
and the position he's in like he almost
looks like like a mummy just sitting in
his tomb or something this one
unfortunately gets cut off but this is a
Christmas Village ceramic figurine and
the eyes on this like it just looks like
when you're walking down a dirty alley
and then you just see these eyes kind of
peering out of the dumpster it's the
same eyes it's the same eyes and then
this one has very weird eyes as well
this is obviously a more recent one it's
taking on the Funko Pop Style and that's
why the eyes are black but kind of
creepy on its own let me know if you
want me to share other weird Grimace
stuff that I found while making the
video